Let's see, where are we going next?
Let's go to let's go to the 4 1 6 area code.
Who's calling today from 4 1 6?
Hello? Yes, that's you.
Yes, it is.
Oh, that's very nice.
Hi, David.
I'm a longtime listener, First-Time Caller.
I'm calling from Toronto, Canada.
Love it.
Great show.
Virtually every day.
I just have a quick question about masks.
Magical like can you give me like a brief
description?
Like what kind of masks are there?
What masks should I wear or shouldn't, you
know, maybe like because some people say I
should wear them at all times.
Some people say they're useless.
Right.
Maybe you know something?
They don't.
OK.
I don't know anything other than what the
health experts say.
I want to make that clear.
So here's mine.
This is a good opportunity to talk about masks.
A couple different things.
Number one, when you talk about masks, there's
a big difference between a scarf, a fabric
mask, a surgical mask and an end 95 mask.
The N-95 mask ordinarily is going to provide
the largest amount of protection, both in
terms of releasing your fluids out of nose
and mouth and allowing other fluids in.
Now, there are these masks I've seen around
which have a valve on them.
A lot of those are one way valves where if
you breathe or sneeze, stuff comes out, but
it protects things coming in.
Those are not the ones, as I understand, that
people should be wearing right now because
they're not keeping things in.
So that that's number one.
Number two, there's this debate over are the
surgical masks and the scarves and the fabric
masks effective or not effective?
And to what degree are they effective?
What we know is regardless of the type of
mask, if you have two people next to each
other.
If neither is wearing a mask and one person
coughs versus if one person is wearing a mask
versus if both are wearing a mask, regardless
of the type of mask, the risk of transmission
is lower if both people are wearing the mask.
Now, if they're crappy masks, the attenuation
is going to be moderate, but it'll still add
up if both people, you'll reduce the chance
of transmission.
So in terms of what kind of mask, listen,
the most effective is an N95.
You can get the Cayenne at 95, which is it's
a Chinese made supposedly up to the same standard
mask.
There's debate over whether individuals should
really be getting a ninety fives because you
are potentially taking them away from a health
care worker without stepping into the supply
piece.
What I'm doing is anytime I go indoors somewhere,
I'm wearing a mask.
I think from what I've seen, Dr. Foushee and
others say that outdoor contagion, unless
you're crowded at, you know, a hiking trail
is almost not like the vast majority of the
contagion is happening within people's own
households than it's happening at people's
workplaces.
It's happening in health care settings.
But the outdoor contagion, you know, some
articles floated around about, you know, you
could jog past someone and you could cough.
Right, as they breathe in and then they've
got the virus.
There is essentially no evidence I've seen
that that is going on.
So when I am just walking around, I am not
wearing a mask at this point in time.
OK.
And you said you wear a mask indoors.
Is it surgical or is it like you've made it
on your own?
Actually, a viewer who makes them and sells
them sent me a couple.
And it's it's a fabric mask.
And so your average mask.
Oh, I see.
I'm just walking in a place where, you know,
I have a few customers come by once in a while.
So I'm you know, it's very hard to get masks
in Toronto.
And I don't want to take them away from medical
workers if they need them.
Yes.
At this point, though, it should be pretty
easy to get the surgical masks.
Not that not in ninety fives you can get.
My understanding is from what I've seen, I
don't know Amazon, Canada, but in the U.S.
you can get a 50 pack of surgical masks for
like 30 bucks.
Yeah, but I remember like a few weeks ago
it was 150.
Not right is like five times.
So.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Now you're absolutely right.
Very confusing.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you, Dave.
All right, my friend.
Thank you.
Great to hear from you in Toronto.
Very much.
Appreciate it.